ja ich habe mich heute morgen mal
hingesetzt beim frühstück und etwas
zahlen gequatscht und zwar schon vor der
meldung die zahlen gehen runter die sich
ja dann als irrtum herausgestellt hat
war am wochenende einfach weniger
fallzahlen übermittelt werden
aber trotzdem war das ergebnis extrem
interessant und wie ich meinen bart
erhalte dass er weiterhin für atemmasken
passt da habe ich auch etwas neues
angefangen also das ist jetzt alles bei
kings und science fiction gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst er nichts los gehts ja
herzlich willkommen
wegen diesen masken musste mich muss ich
ja mein bart etwas stutzen damit hier
unten eben die maske wirklich nicht
abschließt das kann sich ein ft2 maske
die reichen also es gibt auch fp3 da
kommen keine viren durch aber wir
fliegen nicht durch die luft in diesem
fall sondern das sind ja tröpfchen das
heißt die werden wirklich aufgehalten
von dieser maske und sie ist halt
wirklich dicht und irrtum übrigens
korrigiert man atmet nicht ihr durch den
filter also durch diese mitte ein das
ist ein ventil zum ausatmen sondern
durch die ganze maske die ist statisch
aufgeladen und zieht alles was in der
luft ist im gewebe an und das bleibt
dann auch da drin so jetzt kann ich mein
nassrasierer man lassen sie liehen
rausnehmen und muss jetzt mal vorsichtig
anfangen also zerschneidet man sich
immer mit den nassrasierer war das ist
schon besser als trocken rasieren
ich habe ja auch einen extra hier
vergrößerung spiegel
[Musik]
st
habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht
ich dreh mich richtig cremig rühren dass
zahl anfang
und mein blut der wahnsinn so und jetzt
muss ich mich und dabei und deswegen
will ich nicht filmen und sich auf das
bad weil es geht nichts über im bad
putzen weil ja da kann man sich komplett
ist kann man komplett alles nass machen
und ja und danach dürfen sich ab und
alles ist sehr schnell blitzeblank ja
und jetzt zeige ich mal wie ich im
studio so drehe ich habe eine große
kollabo mit einfach medizin wirklich
tollen kanal unbedingt auf youtube
abonnieren
und ja so geht das wenn ich drehe und
schneider so hier sehe ich übrigens so
drehe ich dass mein iphone das ist ein
titel promoter und dann läuft jetzt an
text steuerlich hier selber während ich
moderiere mit einer bluetooth
fernbedienung die kamera stellt sehr gut
auf ja und dann geht's los die lösung
man kann für das die lösung man kann für
das saas kauf 2 testen nächstes problem
hier jetzt jetzt geht's in den schnitt
das ist ja jetzt für ein fach medizin
ich muss ja jetzt nicht viel schneiden
sondern muss es nur hochladen damit
martin das dann in sein video rein
schneiden kann ja das mit den zahlen
dass ich schon ein bisschen verrückter
geisterte jetzt die meldung durchs netz
die zahlen würden runter gehen aber dann
legte das robert-koch-institut der
rückwärtsgang ein und erklärte dass am
wochenende sowieso weniger fälle
gemeldet würden aber ich habe mir mal
die zahlen vorgenommen und habe für
jeden tag die fallzahlen eingetragen und
dann habe ich mir mal raus gerechnet wie
jeden tag die prozentuale steigerung war
und das ganze sieht dann so aus das sind
die blauen punkte das heft ziemlich rauf
und runter
ja und so sieht die steigerung skore
dazu aus sie sieht erstmal ganz klar
exponentiell aus aber die steigt doch
eben man sieht an den blauen punkten
immer etwas anders und das hat sich hier
sehr langsam eingependelt mit immer
größeren zahlen aber trotzdem man sieht
hier dass es einen ganz leichten trend
der steigerungsraten nach unten gibt das
ist schon mal ein positives zeichen es
muss natürlich dann auf null gehen das
ist ganz wichtig denn nur dann kann die
überlastung der krankenhäuser vermieden
werden ja also spannende zahlen sie
gehen eben doch nach unten ganz langsam
und ja wir müssen mal abwarten was ich
jetzt nächste woche tut es spricht wenig
dafür dass tatsächlich die maßnahmen
gegriffen haben aber ich kann nur noch
mal betonen bleibt zu hause
es wirkt es muss auf null kommen also
bitte bitte bitte haltet euch an die
anweisung keine kontakte bleibt
möglichst zuhause
haltet abstand und ansonsten halte ich
euch auf dem laufenden hier im video
tagebuch
hier gibt's noch mehr von mir aus meinem
leben hier in quarantäne und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran